à monsieur messaoudène merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france vous avez
d'autres races participé à ce
rassemblement il semble que vous soyez
revenu chez vous à l'heure qu'il est
racontez nous parce qu'au début c'était
une manifestation très calme qui semble
avoir dégénéré à l'heure qu'il est alors
effectivement le rassemblement a duré
très longtemps il y avait beaucoup de
prises de paroles moi ce que j'ai noté
j'ai pas forcément envie de commenter
les heures parce que je sais que c'est
ce que vous voulez à retenir certaines
personnes à commencer par le préfet
didier lallement qui a voulu interdire
ce temps rassemblement dont qui a jeté
de l'huile sur le feu puis je rappelle
que didier lallement
les personnes qui ont envahi
périphériques donc effectivement vous
savez aussi bien que moi vous connaissez
les médias l'endettement on va forcément
et nécessairement retenir ces images de
violence sur la séquence
c'est pour ça madame c'est pour ça
madame que moi je reviens sur ce qui
s'est passé avant le périphérique n'a
pas été envahie par assa traoré sa
famille il a été envahi par des gens
s'est passé pas des choses que j'ai
forcément envie de commenter ce que je
dis c'est qu'il reste vingt ans son aîné
pardonnez moi juste être quelqu'un ce
que vous condamnez justement ce genre
d'attitude ou les justifier non moi je
dis juste qu'il ya une colère légitime
dans ce pays
face aux violences policières et il faut
l'entendre il ya un test qui est sorti
ya pas très longtemps justement
là-dessus pour dire que la colère des
quartiers populaires étaient légitimes
il ya des familles aujourd'hui dans ce
pays et madame qui ne peuvent toujours
pas faire le deuil de leurs enfants tués
par les forces de l'ordre parce que la
justice n'ait toujours pas rendu donc je
je je refuserai toujours de comparer ce
qui n'est pas comparable
tout à l'heure avant que vous me
montriez ces images il y avait un
rassemblement avec des centaines de
personnes venues de partout des jeunes
des moins jeunes des personnes blanches
des personnes non blanches qui sont
venus avec la vérité et justice pour
adama traoré mais également pour sabri
décédé à argenteuil récemment et dans
une affaire dans laquelle la police
était encore là impliqué ce qu'on est
venu dénoncer tout à l'heure madame
c'est l'impunité de la police qui est la
règle dans combien de policiers sont
allés en prison a pas avoir tué des gens
aucun c'est à dire que tant que la
police ne sera pas que
tant que l'impunité sera la règle tant
que les hiérarchies administratives et
politiques et le parquet décideront que
les policiers ne sont jamais
responsables de la mort qui de cause
alors la colère continuera lourde et
dans ce pays il faut juste l'entendre
les gens qui sont venus total à ne sont
pas venus pour fo le violent et sont
dues pour dénoncer la violence d'un
corps constitués qu'ils appellent la
police nationale et qui s'appelle
également la gendarmerie sept ans
d'armorique qui a tué adama traoré en
2016 le jour de ses 24 ans donc c'est ça
qu'on est venu dénoncer tout à l'heure
ces violences policières on n'en peut
plus
on n'en peut plus de compter nos morts
on n'en peut plus de voir des familles
endeuillées
on n'en peut plus de voir des mères qui
pleurent leurs enfants et qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire le deuil parce que des
policiers ne sont toujours pas gt c'est
ça qu'on est venu dire à la face à
l'eire aujourd'hui a défendu la police
en tout comme le préfet vous l'avez cité
didier lallement lollichon selon le
ministre de l'intérieur qui protège dans
ce pays les femmes et les hommes de tout
y compris du racisme effectivement il y
à certaines voix qui dénoncent une forme
de racisme dans la police est ce que
vous en faites partie clairement mais
clairement il y à du racisme dans la
police d'ailleurs pourquoi il n'y aurait
pas de racisme dans la police quand il y
en a dans la société enfin je veux dire
c'est tout à fait incohérent de 2,2 de
dire qu'il n'y aurait pas de racisme
dans la police le problème en plus qui
se rajoute quand il ya du racisme dans
la police et que les policiers sont
armés et quand ces policiers sont armés
notamment dans des quartiers populaires
bas ça se transforme
hélas souvent en violences policières
mortels ou non et tous les jours des
jeunes dans les quartiers populaires se
font taper par les policiers c'est
quelque chose qui est notoire le fait de
vouloir être dans le déni comme l'est le
préfet l'allemand s'est juste
inacceptables on voit bien que c'est pas
lui qui vit tous les jours des contrôles
facétieux je vous rappelle madame qu'en
2016 la cour de cassation a condamné
l'état français pour contrôles au faciès
donc comment peut-on dire aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y a pas de racisme dans la
police il faut réformer la jouer la
question que je pose des questions non
mais ses blessures rhétorique madame
c'est à dire que je sais très bien vous
faites votre travail et que vous posez
la question à me donner l'occasion de
répondre
absolument ce que je vous dis madame
c'est que ya du racisme dans la police
que ce racisme
il des fois il tue et on l'a vu dans les
quartiers populaires c'est trop mais
depuis de trop nombreuses années
bastamag a fait un dossier dans lequel
il recense entre 2007 et 2017
une soixantaine de jeunes de deux morts
deux personnes qui ont croisé de forces
de l'ordre avec trois condamnations et
euros policiers en prison voilà le
résultat de l'igpn qui ne sert qu'à
blanchir les violences policières et les
meurtres commis par dans la police en
gros il faut qu'on arrête avec nous
madjid messaoudene tout à l'heure vous
soulignez à juste titre effectivement
que la manifestation avait été calme
pendant plusieurs heures il n'empêche on
rappelle que cette manifestation était
interdite par la préfecture de police de
paris pour deux raisons parce que voilà
n'était pas apparemment déclaré selon la
préfecture et deuxièmement parce que on
est en crise sanitaire et qu'aujourd'hui
tout simplement les rassemblements de
plus de 10 personnes sur la voie
publique sont interdits pour tout le
monde pour tout à chacun
est ce que vous êtes étonnés justement
que les choses dégénèrent de la sorte
alors qu'à la base c'était une
manifestation tout simplement interdite
par moi ce qui me choque davantage c'est
je sais pas si je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est que monsieur l'allemand se
servent de cette crise sanitaire de cet
état d'urgence sanitaire pour interdire
les mobilisations citoyennes comme
celles d'un mât traoré si le
rassemblement appelé par le comité à
damas n'était pas seul et n'avait pas
été sur les violences policières
didier lallement ne l'aurait pas
interdit il est insupportable pour les
forces de l'ordre à 110 personnes sur
leur vie que personne n'y échappe à
renens augmente maman va en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il ya eu un
rassemblement a bondi hier pour gabriel
qui a pu se tenir ils étaient plus de 10
sauf que gabriel sur son cas n'est pas
si vide adama traoré et d'après les
pensions politique que compris à capri
le comité adam a donc on va bien qu'en
fait il ya deux poids deux poids deux
mesures je me félicite il est plus tenir
a bondi de rassemblement ce que je note
c'est que des policiers sont allés au
domicile face à traoré aujourd'hui pour
l'intimider et empêcher que le
rassemblement ne se tienne ou alors on
en est aujourd'hui
dans ce pays il faut qu on puisse
manifester contre les violences
policières dans ce pays et qu'on est
contre tout ce qu'on trouve d'injuste et
d'heures et de révoltant et ce n'est pas
ce qu'on s'asseye terre qu'ils ont
nous en sera et c'est ce qui a vous le
dira ça traoré en maintenant le comment
dire le rassemblement aujourd'hui ni
heurts qui ont émaillé ces
rassemblements ne peuvent pas être ne
peuvent pas résumer ce qui s'est passé
tout à l'heure mais encore une fois on
parle de vies humaines
on parle de vies humaines pas de dégâts
matériels ce sont des vies qui sont
volés par les forces de l'ordre
chaque année dans ce pays merci beaucoup
m'a dit d'un messaoudène d'avoir un t
rex vous conseiller municipal de seine
saint denis